abone ol ne
yapmak oldukça güzel anlattı ben ne
diyeceğim şimdi şaşırdım bu bilgiler ben
size vermedim Siz internetten bulduğumuz
galiba da mı
Neyse Hoş geldiniz ismim Adem
normalde çok heyecanlı oluyorum böyle
konuşmalarda ama bugün nedense çok rahat
Amsterdam'da doğdum büyüdüm Aynen de
söylediğim gibi arkadaşımızın ve
ortadoğu büyük sonradan Türkiye gelmenin
avantajlarından biraz bahsedeceğim
bugünkü konumuz before-after
tıbu video arkamdaki slayt de eski
şişman halini göstermek isterdim size
sonra incecik olup tekrar geri kilo
aldığımı göstermek istedim ama maalesef
ki Türkiye'de eski halini bu
şişman halini göstermek
algısı biraz yani Ezik gibi
bana kasa gösterim hiç sıkıntı yok ama
olayımız aldı ya Bu algıdan biraz
bahsetmek istiyorum
2005'te Kendi şirketimi başladı dijital
pazarlama ve işimiz
var sıfırdan başlayan şirketlerin
hazırlamasını yapmak
Türklere yabancıları olan Dallara kim
olursa olsun hiç unutamıyorum bir tane
bir sürücü kursu vardı
Sürücü Kursu budakta ismi
bu Budak
O ne alaka tedip
arabaya binecek olan yabancı Hollandalı
ya sarışın senin sürücü kursunun
kursunun ismi Budak
o kadar saçma sapan şeylerle karşılaştık
ki orada kendi insanımızın algısı nasıl
düzeltebiliriz yani 2015'ten 2016'ya
kadar Onunla uğraştım ve Google öğrendik
İnterneti her şeyi
çözdüm ve duyduğunuz üzere Türkçem o
kadar iyi değil sen bunu
maruz mazur
neyse işte
durum böyle olunca
2016'da şirketimin en iyi zamanlarında
Türkiye dönüş kararı aldım neden döndüm
onu anlatmayacağım Çünkü konumuz bu gün
bir forfaiter
Türkiye'ye geldim aslında
Bu eurolar da geliyor ya şirketten yani
Gelip yazacaktım ama dayanamadım bir
drone aldım
çekimler yaptım keşifler yaptım ve hiç
unutamıyorum
Güney Şelalesi Antalya'da da Rus yogacı
toplum kadınlar beni davet etti Gel bizi
çektin Hayatımda ilk defa o kadar Ulus
kadın bir arada görüyorum ben de Koşarak
gittim tabii ki de
bu ama sarışınlara alışkınım Hollanda'da
o bi' ayrı mesela Neyse orada
olabildiğince güzel çekim yaptı oldukça
profesyonel
ve hiçbir ücret talep etmedim
Ne bileyim yogacı kadınların arasında üç
tanesi otelde çalıştığını pazarlamacı
olarak
çağırdılar bize de bir çekim yaptırdılar
gittim orada da çekim yaptım demolar
Yani doğru hatırlıyorsan yaklaşık bir
sene boyunca
bu işi öğrenebilmek için
çekimler yaptım otellere
reklamlara
Alanya'ya Antalya Yeni yerler keşfettim
Isparta Iğdır orası burası Yani sürekli
çekime kendimi adadım Ve bunu yaparken
de
pazarlamacı tecrübemi kullanmaya
çalıştım o da nedir Yani şimdi bir
paylaşım yapıyorsun bir soru alıyorum
ağabey hangi durumu markasını
kullanıyorum bu soruyu soranın bana
zerre kadar bir faydası olmaz bu
yapabileceği tek bir iş var o durağında
aynı çekimleri yapıp veya düğün
videoları çekmek vesaire Yani kısacası
ben orada şunu gördüm Hedef kitlenin
doğru olmadığı
bu Okey
drone görüntüleri azaltalım o zaman
Sonra bunun bir de psikolojik bir boyut
var seyahat videoları çekiyoruz ya
Okulun bir araştırmasına göre
Biz Türkler Web siteleri
bu araştırmayı çok fazla yapmıyoruz çok
fazla Web siteleri kullanmıyoruz yemek
yemeyi tatile gitmeyi
bir şeyler araştırmayı haberi hepsini
biz aynı araştırmada
Instagram'dan alıyoruz de okey dedim bu
seyahatleri belirleyen Kim bu
seyahatleri gidilecek yerlere
Instagram'dan en çok tercih edelim
kadınlar
bu Kadınlara yönelik paylaşımlar yapalım
dedim mi Orada şunu gördüm
Dükkanı kolay kolay seyahat eden bir
uzaklara bakan aracıyla fotoğraflar
çekinen bir erkeği takip etmez bu Okey
geliştirdim konsepti
mewo
önden Jürgen o kadın akımını başlattı
kendim değilim artık olay kendimi komple
sıfırladım O yüzden beni görmüyorsunuz
videolarda ve yürüyen kadın videolarıyla
sıradışı keşiflerle
sayfa6
gittim büyüdü
ve sayfanın büyümesiyle de bu işi nasıl
daha geliştirebilirim daha nasıl
profesyonel yapabilirim derken yani o
zamanlar 100 200 bin takipçi var du du
ve
daha iyi nasıl yapabilirim derken altına
metinleri de ciddi bir araştırma sonucu
yaptı
bunu da hiç unutamıyorum Zonguldak'a
gitti soru-cevap yaptım Zonguldak'ta
nereye gidilir
o uzakta herkes beni bir mağaraya
sokmaya çalıştım ya da Karadeniz Ereğli
diye bir yer varmış oraya göndermeye
çalıştım ama biraz araştırdım
Ankara'ya yakın en güzel yaylanın
Zonguldak'ta olduğunu biliyor muydu
büyüklüğü Yaylası
ne Instagram açtım hiç bir tane paylaşım
yok
yani Ayder Rize yayları ana taş
çıkarabilecek bir yayla
orada bir çekim yaptım ve bunun
pazarlamasını
algısını
sayfamda
Ankara'ya yakın bir yer
yazdık Zonguldak'tan bahsetmiyorum
bu uçtu
o Zonguldak Valisi davet Zonguldak
Belediye Başkanı davet ederken
gitti
tabi burada bu bu yazıları hazırlarken
araştırma yaparken çok ciddi bir bir
profesyonelliğe
paylaştığını her şeye dikkat etmek
zorunda kalıyor Çünkü bu herkese hitap
etmek istiyorum
her yaştan kişilere hitap etmek
istiyorum ve sayfa büyüdükçe
sorumluluğunda artıyor var hiç
beklemediğim olmadığım bir pozisyona de
işte
o Hollanda'da bir
form müşterilerimin hizmetini yaparak
şirketlerini büyütürken
ef4 Türkiye'de
kendi işimi nasıl büyütebilirim kendime
nasıl bir yatırım yapabilirim sürekli
bunun araştırmasını
O çok zamanımı aldı
var
yani şu ise ne Bir buçuk sene boyunca
Beş kuruş para kazanıyorsun
sürekli Instagram'a içerik üretiyoruz
amacın kendini geliştirmek Ve bu konuda
uzman olabilmek
birileri bana bir ürün göndersin Ondan
sonra ne bileyim seyahatleri çıkayım
veya ne bileyim oteller davet ettin
falan filan değil hiçbir şey yok ki
günümüz gençliğinin bütün hayali şu an
ve ben de ezeyim
Gittiğin yerleri paylaşayım bana para
versinler veya ne bileyim konaklama
versinler yok Yok öyle bir dünya yok
ben onu yapmadan önce ciddi bir yatırım
olması gerekir O yatırımda sosyal
medyada Ben Fenomen kelimesinden gıcık
kapıyor
yani Fenomen kelimesi tesadüf olunan bir
şeymiş gibi geliyor bana
yan gelip yatanların işiymiş gibi
geliyor bana halbuki bu işi ciddi
yapanlar
bari ismi içerik üretiriz
bu ve buna Instagram sahibi de istiyorum
contents böceğidir
bu ve içeriğin güzel oldu mu insanlara
ilham olabiliyoruz
ne demiştim bir sorumluluğum artıyor ya
bu sorumluluk arttıktan sonra
Affet dönemlerinde de yani Bu çalıştığım
bölgelerde bir olay olduğunda Tabi onu
da paylaşmak istedim
birçoğunuz Beni görmeden belki yangın
döneminde geçen sene paylaştığım
videoları hatırlayabilirsiniz
o dönemde de 10 milyon 30 milyon Hatta
50 milyona yakın izlenen bir bir sürecim
oldu ve hiçbir zaman kendimi ön plana
değil olan olayı içerikleri ön plana
çıkarmaya çalış anlatmak istediğim olay
afterda Türk'ü güzel bir söz var Kalite
tesadüf değildir diyorlar ya Ya ben en
kaliteli olarak yani ön plana sürmüyorum
ben kaliteli olduğunu da iddia etmiyorum
ama
rakamlarda yalan söylemiyor
teşekkür ederim